F-Wi Sout fighting falcon không chỉ là một tiêm thích, mà là việc tên quanh gầu về sự mạnh, sự linh hoạt và độ tiên cạnh của không quân hiện đại.
Già mắt tự nằm một miền chính trăm bệ mỹ tư, F-Wi Sout chỉ mấy mây chỉ có một đập cơ duy nhất,
nhưng lại thích hợp áo sài em ở só một tụt càn hai người bị đi mát, cùng hàng lạc của khi thuộc mình,
tựa tên được không đối không, không đối đất đến bỏng giận gở mạng lây giờ.
Chính hợp thích hẹt tối u, chỉ biết bận hành hợp mi và hành tích y tạo, F-Wi Sout nhìn chống chiếm lính thị trường có khoảng quan cầu,
có mặt trong khiến chế không quân của hơn 2 mệt tự quốc gia từ nát tôi để cho à ở định dường.
F-Wi Sout lúc bẩy người là phía bản nân cấp sâu nhất của sòng F-Wi Sout không chỉ mạnh trong mình công nghệ chỉ đấu thế hệ bốn phẩy năm.
Mà còn sự quyền sự gọi, cơ đậu, yếu tối làm linh thương hiệu của chiếm ương chỉ đấu.
Mấy bài có trường dải mùi lâm phải không xong mét và trường cao bốn phải 3 tà mét, xải cánh chỉ phải chính xong mét, với trọng lượng dậu khoảng 3.
F-Wi Sout lúc phải nguyên có thể xích cánh với trọng lượng tối đa người thêm đi bốt tỉnh, măng xong dùng phải tỉnh của khi trên chỉ tiếp theo.
Ví thức gọn gần, khi được tối u về kiếm đậu học và vật lượng chiếc tạo, giúp F-Wi Sout lúc phải nguyên, tặt tất lượng tối đa nền tới mắc 2 và khả năng cơ đậu cựt cao,